-Welcome, everybody.
I'm so happy to have you
here, friends and colleagues
to Radcliffe Day 2016.
And let me just say
before I get started
that I know it's warm in here.
And I invite you to
take off your jackets.
Do whatever it takes
to be comfortable.
I'm Liz Cohen, Dean of
the Radcliffe Institute.
As Harvard's Institute
for Advanced Study,
Radcliffe convenes
faculty and students
from all of Harvard's schools
and audiences from far
beyond our gates
to share inquiry
into the arts, humanities,
sciences, and social sciences.
That is why I am delighted
to welcome so many of you
today, both here in
Cambridge and online,
to join in our
annual celebration.
I am especially pleased to
welcome Drew Faust, Harvard
President and Founding
Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute, Provost Alan
Garber, and Bill Lee, Senior
Fellow of the
Harvard Corporation,
along with other members
of Harvard's governing
boards, the Harvard Alumni
Association, the Radcliffe
Deans Advisory Council,
the Schlesinger Library
Council, the Radcliffe
Associates Program, the Anne
Radcliffe Society, as well as
past members of the Radcliffe
College Board of Trustees
and Alumni Association.
We are very excited to have a
United States Attorney General
Loretta Lynch, class of 1981,
Harvard Law School, class
of 1984 with us today as well.
And, of course, we are
thrilled to have Janet Yellen,
Chair of the Board of Governors
of the Federal Reserve
as our 2016 Radcliffe Medalist.
And a special welcome to former
Chair of the Fed Ben Bernanke
and to Harvard Professor
of Economics Greg
Mankiw for helping us pay
tribute to our guest of honor.
Welcome, as well,
to the very few
of you here today hoping
to get advance word on what
the Fed will do with interest
rates at its June meeting.
I would like to recognize
the reunion classes of 1941,
'46, '51, '56, '61,
'66, '71, '76, '86, '91.
Did I forget one?
'81, '86, '91, '96, 2001,
2006, 2011, and our newest
graduates in the class of 2016.
We also welcome former
Bunting Fellows,
current and former
Radcliffe Fellows,
and the Harvard
undergraduates who
so ably serve as our
fellows' research partners.
Everyone, please join me
in congratulating members
of the earliest class
represented here today,
the great class of 1939.
All of us gathered
under this tent
are joined by an even larger
audience watching online.
To the viewers who have told
us that they would be watching
in Japan and to all of
you tuning in from afar,
my warmest welcome.
As we come together
on Radcliffe day
we think of classmates and
friends no longer with us.
Please join me in
a moment of silence
to honor their memories.
When Elizabeth Cary
Agassiz and her colleagues
founded Radcliffe
College in 1879,
they knew that the world needed
the best minds, women and men,
working together to forge
a world of action informed
by ideas.
This mission continues at
the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study today.
Let me share a few
highlights from the year
we have just completed.
We have enjoyed more than 50
enlightening presentations
from Radcliffe Fellows.
To name just three--
anthropologist
Laurence Ralph discussed
police brutality in Chicago.
Choreographer Karole
Armitage spoke
about creating meaning
through movement.
And author Michael
Pollan delivered
an autobiographical talk about
his trajectory as a writer.
An exhibition of feminist poetry
at the Schlesinger Library
opened with powerful
student readings
of their own original poems
and the work of acclaimed poets
like June Jordan and Adrienne
Rich, Radcliffe class of 1951,
whose papers grace the
Schlesinger's collections.
That exhibition entitled
"A Language to Hear Myself"
is open today and will remain
open through June 17th.
I hope you will make
a point of visiting.
Our annual science symposium
investigated the past, present,
and future of DNA.
While our annual
Gender Conference
examined the fascinating
and timely topic
of language and gender.
All year we collaborated
with the Harvard University
Native-American program
to explore issues related
to Native Americans in the
US and indigenous peoples
worldwide.
We organized new
research projects,
compelling public events, a
major conference, performances,
and more.
An exhibition
featuring photographs
of Native American
women is on display
in the Johnson-Kulukundis
Gallery in Byerly Hall.
Please stop by
after lunch today.
This exhibit is
the most recent use
of our newly renovated
gallery, which we just
opened this academic year.
We had high hopes
that this new space
would provide a creative
laboratory for experimentation
and original expression by
a wide circle of artists
and scholars.
It has fulfilled those
hopes from the very first
installation, by Team Lab, an
innovative Japanese collective
of computer scientists
and artists.
Since then, Radcliffe
Fellows, including
filmmakers and a composer,
have shared their work
in the gallery.
More information and videos
of this year's exhibitions
and events are on our website.
And ambitious plans are
under way for next year.
We'll be holding conferences
on subjects ranging
from the world's endangered
oceans to gender and sports,
and from the international
refugee crisis to slavery
and universities.
The Schlesinger
Library will continue
to diversify its holdings
by collecting even more
archives of
individuals and groups
whose stories contribute to a
fuller picture of US history.
We will hold a panel
discussion about the challenges
and rewards of collecting
the papers of one such group,
political conservatives.
Our fellowship
program will welcome
more than 50 new
Fellows, coming here
from six continents,
who will pursue
an astonishing
array of projects,
from novels and operas to the
history of the civil rights
movement, to epigenetics
and black holes.
The support of many of you
right here in this tent
makes all of these
programs possible.
We are in the midst
of a major capital
campaign for Radcliffe's
future, expertly
chaired by Sid Knafel
and Susan Wallach.
More than 6,300 households
have made over 17,000 gifts,
totaling $55 million dollars.
We are approaching 80%
of our $70 million goal.
And I am especially grateful
and proud that our donors come
from all 13 Harvard schools,
50 states, 23 countries,
and every class since 1933.
When Elizabeth Cary
Agassiz founded Radcliffe
with her vision of the world's
best minds leading together,
she also had the
courage to imagine women
at the helm of that world.
I think she would be very
pleased to see us awarding
the Radcliffe Medal
today to the individual
that CNN and NBC News have
called "the most powerful woman
in the world."
She went like that.
Janet Yellen was born and
raised in Brooklyn, New York.
Her mother was a former teacher.
Her father was a
family doctor, who
saw patients at home, a
common practice at the time.
Many patients were dock
workers and their families.
These working families
made a deep impression
on the young Janet, because
dock work, by its nature,
was vulnerable to economic
fluctuation, which
meant frequent periods
of unemployment.
From her earliest
memories, she understood
that its effects
were, in her words,
"simply terrible on the mental
and physical health of workers,
on their marriages, and on
their children," end quote.
The human effects of the
labor market and the urge
to do something about
them would go on
to shape Yellen's
remarkable career.
Growing up, Janet Yellen
excelled at everything.
As Editor-in-Chief of the Fort
Hamilton High School newspaper,
she was charged with the duty
of interviewing the senior class
valedictorian, which
turned out to be a very
awkward assignment.
As you've guessed, she
was the valedictorian.
So she interrogated herself.
Her first tongue-in-cheek
cheek question began with,
I understand that
you are a versatile,
attractive, talented, senior.
The real question was, with so
much talent in so many areas,
which direction would she go?
That question was answered
in her first semester
at Pembroke, which was then
the women's college at Brown
University and a sister
school to Radcliffe College.
In her first economics class,
Janet Yellen found her calling.
Years later, she explained, "I
remember sitting in that class
and learning about how there
were policy decisions that
could have been taken
during the Great Depression
to alleviate all
that human suffering.
That was a real
aha moment for me.
I realized that public
policy can and should
address these problems."
Yellen graduated summa
cum laude and went on
to earn her PhD in
Economics from Yeah in 1971.
She was deeply influenced
by her professors
there to study how government
action can mitigate hardships,
especially unemployment,
caused by market cycles.
Yellen was inspired to
undertake scholarship
that met the highest
intellectual standards
and held the potential to
improve people's lives.
She adhered to that
ideal as she embarked
on a career that tacked back
and forth between academia
and public service.
After graduating
from Yale, Yellen
taught economics
here at Harvard,
until she went to work for
the Federal Reserve in 1977.
One day, she met another
economist, George Akerlof
in the Fed cafeteria.
They hit it off immediately,
married the following year,
and took jobs at the
London School of Economics.
In 1980, the couple
moved to California
to teach at UC Berkeley.
There they wrote some of
their most influential work,
both individually
and collaboratively.
One of their most renowned
jointly authored papers
analyzed why wages sometimes
exceed market minimums.
Yellen and Akerlof
showed, in contrast
to the standard
theory, that it may
be in an employer's
economic interest
to pay higher wages
because workers labor
harder and do better work
when they feel valued.
Another one of Yellen's and
Akerlof's significant findings
grew out of a different
sort of collaboration--
the birth of their son Robert.
The new parents were
looking for childcare
and thinking about their budget.
Yellen remembered vividly, "when
you hire a nanny, the question
you ask yourself is, what's
best for my precious child?
And do you really
want someone who
feels that your motive in
life is to minimize the amount
you spend on your child?"
That experience taught
them that hiring a nanny
is not the time to
hoard your pennies,
no matter what the
market dictates.
They went on to support
this important insight
with a wealth of data
and rigorous analysis,
but their key
contribution was to show
that you can consult
all the models, graphs,
and numbers that you want.
But unless you take into account
both workers' and employers'
non-rational motivations,
including emotions,
you will not be able to predict
or explain the labor market.
In 1994, Yellen took
leave from Berkeley
to join the Federal
Reserve Board of Governors.
Upon arrival, she
raised eyebrows
with a habit that
was out of step
with other senior managers--
eating in the employee
cafeteria.
By eating there,
Yellen learned what
staff members were thinking.
She also communicated
an openness
and a transparency that have
been hallmarks of her tenure
at the Fed.
Yellen served on the
Federal Reserve Board
of Governors until 1997
and then on the White House
Council of Economic Advisers
under President Bill Clinton
from 1997 to '99.
She returned to
teaching briefly,
before becoming President and
CEO of the Federal Reserve
Bank of San Francisco in 2004.
That same year she
published an important paper
with Akerlof that offered a
robust defense of government
action to avoid recession
and to offset the effects
of economic downturn.
Now, scholars love to be timely.
But nobody realized
how painfully relevant
that paper would
soon prove to be.
As 2004 drew to a close,
unemployment rested comfortably
between 5% and 5 and 1/2%.
The stock market ran high.
Housing market was hot.
Corporate earnings
were climbing.
But as Yellen watched it
all from the Federal Reserve
Bank of San Francisco, she
started warning of a bubble
in the housing market.
Hers was a lonely voice.
But as we now know,
she was right.
The worst financial crisis since
the Great Depression unleashed
its fury in the fall of
2008, and what we now call
the Great Recession, followed.
Unemployment nearly doubled.
Stocks plummeted.
Housing prices went
into free fall.
Soon nearly 1/3 of
homeowners nationwide
owed more on their mortgages
than their houses were worth.
The financial sector
was also in big trouble.
Bear Stearns and Lehman
Brothers went under.
Other firms were kept alive
only by federal bailouts.
Credit disappeared.
Capital and liquidity
ran dangerously low.
And so things stood in
2010, the year Yellen
became Vice Chair of the Fed,
serving as second in command
to then-chair Ben Bernanke.
It may be hard to
see why anyone would
want to take that job in the
depths of an economic disaster.
But if we think back to
the little girl who was so
touched by her father's
unemployed patients
or to the young woman who
decided in her first economics
class that government
could and should
be an effective and trusted
force for the public good,
then it makes sense that
Yellen would roll up
her sleeves, determined
to aid household recovery
and promote renewed
economic mobility.
Normally, monetary policy's
first line of defense
would be to lower
short-term interest rates.
But interest rates are
already at or near zero.
Facing stormy seas
and fiscal headwinds,
the Fed had to right
the ship with limited
access to monetary
policy's usual instruments.
As Chair, Bernanke skillfully
guided the Fed away
from its customary
closed-mouth habits,
summed up by the slogan
"never explain, never excuse,"
and toward new habits
of transparency.
Yellen was crucial to fostering
this new sense of openness.
She led a
communications committee
with the same refreshing
candor that she
had brought to lunch in
the employee cafeteria.
As she put it, "I hope
and trust that the days
of 'never explain, never
excuse' are gone for good."
The Fed shored up
consumer confidence
and prevented the
crisis from worsening.
But conditions
remain challenging,
as Bernanke's term as
Chair drew to a close.
A woman had never
chaired the Fed.
But President Barack
Obama nominated Yellen.
She began her term
on February 1, 2014.
With her values, her intellect,
and her calm leadership,
Yellen steers our economy
toward shared prosperity.
She replaces the popular Main
Street versus Wall Street
dichotomy with the
claim that Main Street
needs a properly regulated Wall
Street, just as a healthy Wall
Street needs a
thriving Main Street.
As she has pointed
out time and again,
a well-supervised
financial sector
fuels job creation, innovation,
and inclusive economic growth.
And in turn, households capable
of meeting financial goals,
such as home
ownership, retirement,
and college savings, are
better able to boost markets.
For Yellen, the key is careful
monitoring, through capital
liquidity requirements,
stress tests
for financial
institutions, and living
wills for firms'
orderly dissolution
in the event of insolvency.
Yellen's leadership was
tested last December,
when, for the first
time in over nine years,
the Federal Reserve
raised interest rates.
Speculation about an increase
had circulated for months.
And then, as now, the topic
was fraught, to say the least.
Some commentators
criticized Yellen
for not raising
rates soon enough.
Other nervous voices
warned that raising rates
would lead to another downturn.
Normally understated
publications, like The New York
Times threw around
adjectives like
"perilous" and "hazardous."
Yellen remained unflappable.
When rates rose, markets,
the public, and the media all
responded calmly,
thanks in large measure
to her resolute demeanor.
The economy is by no
means perfect today,
but when Yellen
addresses the public,
the markets usually respond with
what USA Today characterizes
as a "Yellen Rally."
Through it all, Yellen
steadfastly describes her role
as Fed Chair in terms
that are both principled
and unpretentious.
To quote her, "the
job isn't just
about fighting
inflation or monitoring
the financial system.
It's about trying to help
ordinary households to get back
on their feet and about
creating a labor market,
where people can feel secure
and work and get ahead."
In a few moments we
will have the pleasure
of getting to know this
extraordinary woman
a bit better.
Nobody is better
suited to help us do so
than Professor Greg Mankiw.
Professor Mankiw is a Harvard
economist and the teacher
of one of the college's most
heavily subscribed courses, EC
10.
Like Yellen, he maintains one
foot in the academic world
and the other in
the policy world.
In his case, he served
as Chair of the Council
of Economic Advisers under
President George W. Bush.
But before Professor Mankiw's
conversation with Chair Yellen,
we will have the good
fortune of hearing
from the single individual
who probably has the greatest
insight into Yellen's
current role,
because he is only
one of three people
alive who has also inhabited it.
I am speaking of former
Fed Chair Ben Bernanke.
Bernanke grew up
in South Carolina.
He grew up in South Carolina.
He graduated from
Harvard College in 1975,
and he earned a PhD
in Economics at MIT.
He taught at Stanford, before
moving to Princeton in 1985.
As much as he enjoyed teaching,
after nearly a quarter
century of it,
Bernanke had begun
to wonder, in his own words,
"what good was economics,
if it's not used to improve
policymaking and therefore
make people better off?"
He has answered his own question
with years of public service
on President George W. Bush's
council of Economic Advisers
as well as on the
Federal Reserve,
to which he was appointed
by President Bush
and reappointed by
President Obama.
These days Ben Bernanke
is a distinguished
Fellow-in-Residence
at the Hutchins Center
on Fiscal and Monetary Policy
at the Brookings Institution,
returning largely to
a life of scholarship.
I am delighted that
we could pull him
back into the limelight today
to share his reflections
on fellow economist
and his successor
as Chair of the Federal
Reserve, Janet Yellen.
Please join me again in
warmly welcoming Ben Bernanke.
-Thank you very much. it's
great to be back in Boston,
where I spent many
years as a student.
And I got over the
Red Sox by 2005,
when the Nationals
moved to Washington.
So I'm glad to be here
on this lovely day.
It's a pleasure for me to
introduce Janet Yellen, someone
for whom I have the greatest
admiration, respect,
and affection.
She's an outstanding
policymaker, an outstanding
person, and we're lucky to
have her leading the Federal
Reserve.
Of course, my
appreciation for Janet
has only increased
by the fact that we
are both members of a small
club of current and retired Fed
Chairs.
It's a club that
doesn't meet very often.
A rare exception to this
rule occurred recently
in New York City, when
the four of us-- Yellen,
Bernanke, Greenspan,
and Volcker--
were joined the interviewed
by Fareed Zakaria.
The greatest excitement came
in the middle of the interview,
when Chairman Greenspan
suddenly gave out a loud sneeze.
I remember thinking that if that
occurred a dozen years earlier,
the cable news commentators
would have spent hours
analyzing what that
meant for markets.
Janet also showed central
banking tendencies
kind of early.
Dean Cohen talked
about the story
where she, as
editor of the paper,
had to interview herself as the
valedictorian of the school.
She didn't talk about the
most relevant comment,
though, which was when the
editor asked herself if she
enjoyed working at the paper?
She replied, no comment.
Like a good central
banker, entrusted
with the nation's
monetary policy,
Janet is also cautious
of temperament.
There's an economist
maxim that if you've never
missed an airline flight,
then you're spending
too much time in airports.
Despite this wisdom,
Janet reportedly
arrives hours in advance of
scheduled departure times.
I've heard that her crack
security team at the Fed
continuously
remonstrates with her.
Janet Madam Chair,
we have sirens.
We have flashing lights.
We can skip the security
lines-- to no avail.
Kidding aside, verbal
discipline and caution
in the face of uncertainty
are indeed characteristics
of good central bankers.
But so are the
ability to analyze
complex situations
and the willingness
to take bold action, when
circumstances demand it.
Janet has both these qualities.
I will forever be grateful to
her for her support and insight
that she provided when we
served together at the Fed
during some very
difficult years.
In her role as President
of the San Francisco Fed,
where she gained
hands-on experience
in supervising banks,
and later as Vice Chair,
she was consistently prescient,
as the Dean described,
about the peril that an
imploding financial system
posed for the economy as
well as about the risk
that the economic
recovery that followed
could be very slow
and protracted.
Throughout the crisis
and its aftermath,
her famously precise and
logical analyzes were frequently
critical for clarifying
the situation
and, equally important,
for persuading others
about the need for action.
I recall how often, when in the
meetings of the Federal Open
Market Committee, which
makes monetary policy, when
it came Janet's turn
to talk, how everyone
would go very silent,
because everyone wanted
to hear the entire argument.
And when it did come time
for action, as ultimately it
always did, She was
a forceful advocate
of doing whatever it takes,
to coin a phrase, to protect
our economy and, in particular,
to put Americans back to work.
She was a terrific colleague
and invaluable ally.
Of course, now Janet is at the
leadership role in the Fed,
where she's continuing
her outstanding work.
When it became apparent in
2013 that she was a leading
candidate for the
position, she came
to talk to me in my office
about whether she should
take the job, if offered.
Now, we both knew
that there could
be no doubt about
her qualifications
for the position.
In her multiple previous roles
at the Fed, as an economist,
as a board member, as a
reserve bank president,
and finally as vice
chair, as well as
in her lifetime of study of
monetary and macroeconomic
issues, Janet probably had
more direct relevant experience
than any other previous chair.
Nevertheless, as I talked
to her about the job,
I wasn't entirely encouraging.
It's a tough job, I said, and
it can be pretty thankless.
Well, Janet recognized
those difficulties, I think,
very honestly.
And she understood the stress
that the position would
put on her and on her family.
But she, of course,
ultimately agreed to serve.
It seemed to me, at
the time, that she
had several motivations for
accepting the president's offer
to be nominated, including
her lifelong commitment
to using what she had
learned as an economist
to improve the lives
of average people.
But I perceived
that she was also
thinking about the
historic significance
of being the first woman
in this prominent post.
I think Janet well understood
that by taking this position
and applying her
considerable talents,
she could provide
a valuable role
model for future generations
of young women, who
might otherwise not
engage with economics
or economic policy-making.
That is, in itself,
a great contribution
on top of all the others
that she has made.
Again let me join the
Dean in honoring Janet.
I'm very pleased
and honored myself
to have been asked to
join this ceremony.
She's an extraordinary
individual and certainly
well-deserving of
today's recognition.
What I'd like to do now is
ask Janet and Greg Mankiw, who
is a Harvard Professor
of Economics,
of course, and also a long time
friend and colleague of mine,
to come up to the
podium-- Janet, Greg.
-Well, welcome back to Harvard.
-Thank you.
-It's a great delight and
honor to be talking with you.
Ben said that central
banking is a thankless job.
So let me begin by thanking
you for all that you do
and have done for this country.
I thought I'd start off with
a little bit of biography.
I've been an economist for many
years, and in all those years
I've never met a five-year-old
who comes up to me and says,
when I grow up, I want
to be an economist.
But some of them do grow up and
become economists, and so there
always some moment
where they say, aha,
this is a career for me.
So at what point
in your life did
you say, aha, I think I'm going
to be an economist, and why?
-OK, let me answer that.
But I'd first like to express
my great gratitude to Dean Cohen
and to Ben for their
wonderful remarks.
I'm really touched and
honored by this award.
And Ben is a good
friend and colleague.
And let me just say
that America owes him
an enormous debt of gratitude.
-OK, so when did you decide
to become an economist?
-So as Dean Cohen mentioned
in her introduction,
I became hooked on economics
when I took Econ 1 or Econ 10
here.
And I think, in part, I'd
always been interested in math,
always enjoyed math.
And I saw economics
as a field that
uses math and uses
quantitative techniques
but for an important
social purpose.
And that is advancing human
welfare and understanding
problems that keep people
from fulfilling their lives.
So it was the social welfare
implications of economics,
plus the analytic rigor that
it involved, was a combination
that appeals to me.
Also, in my first
macroeconomics class,
I studied the Great
Depression and business
cycles more generally.
It was my first exposure
really to Keynesian economics,
to the general theory.
And I think I came to appreciate
that, although I don't think
anyone's ever invented
a better economic system
than capitalism,
and it works very
well for a large
number of purposes,
it is capable of
breakdowns periodically,
in which one has mass
unemployment-- the Great
Depression, the Great
Recession, fortunately
not nearly so serious,
but nevertheless a very
difficult episode.
And I saw that monetary
and fiscal policy
were tools that could be
used to address unemployment
and improve people's lives.
And that attracted me and it's
continued to be my motivation.
-Well, as a teacher of
Principles of Economics
here at Harvard, I'm
actually great to hear
that stat course can
be so transformative
in such important lives.
Now, you mention
Keynesian economics.
I'm going to talk about your
own intellectual pedigree.
When you went to Yale
as a grad student,
you studied with James Tobin.
You know this.
But just to give the audience
a little bit of background,
James Tobin was one of
the great macroeconomists
of the 20th century,
a Nobel Prize winner.
He studied here at Harvard
under Alvin Hansen,
who was one of the early
Keynesian economists.
He's one of the first
people in the United States
to take Keynes very
seriously and bring
a lot of the ideas
of the general theory
to the United States.
So you can see that intellectual
trajectory from Keynes
to Hansen to Tobin to you.
And I actually I
learned at lunch today
that you taught Alan Garber.
-I did.
-So you can see it
continues to today.
Can you tell us a little
bit about your relationship
with Tobin and how that worked?
-Well, I went to Yale, and
I chose Yale as a place
to get my PhD because I
was so impressed by Tobin.
I took his course in
monetary economics.
I served as his
teaching assistant
in the core graduate
macro class.
He was certainly an important
mentor to me and a friend.
And later on, when I went to
serve at the Federal Reserve
and at the Council
of Economic Advisers,
he would visit me in Washington
and give me the benefit
of his policy advice.
But Tobin, to me, was
more than just a teacher.
He was really an inspiration.
And what inspired
me so about Tobin
was that he had a passion
for social justice
and a moral compass that
pointed straight north.
And to him, sometimes
economists are
accused of working on
highly mathematical models,
that the applicability
of them is questionable.
For Tobin, that
was never the case.
Economics was always important
because the policy applications
of it had the potential to
make people's lives better.
As you indicated, he
studied here at Harvard,
read the general theory
shortly after it was published,
lived through the
Depression, saw not
only the horrific economic
toll it took on our nation,
but also the political and
social repercussions of that
for many, many years.
And he was determined to make
sure that our country never
suffered through
such a situation
again, when there were policy
tools that could be deployed.
And that was exactly
the focus that I've
had throughout my career.
-Yeah, I had
noticed, by the way,
as a macroeconomist,
that recessions
do have one positive
byproduct is they to generate
a lot of macroeconomists.
So the Great Depression
generated a whole generation,
including Tobin's generation.
I went to grad school
during the '82 recession.
A lot of people were
interested in macro.
And this recent recession,
the financial crisis,
has got a lot of people
interested in macroeconomics
again.
So there's one little upside
to economic downturns.
So I'm going to think about the
evolution of economic thought.
If you think about what you
learned how the economy works
as a student, both at Brown and
Yale, and what we know today,
what do we know
today that we think
is really fundamental,
important,
that they didn't know back
when you were a student?
-Well, macroeconomics
as a field, I think,
is absolutely
continued to advance.
And Dean Cohen in her remarks
talked about what I'll refer to
was the microeconomic
foundations of macroeconomics.
This is something that not
only did I work on, but, Greg,
you've have made important
contributions to as well.
-Thank you.
-Macroeconomic
theory, I think, was
criticized that wage and price
stickiness or rigidity played
an important role in
understanding unemployment.
But the economic foundations,
the micro foundations
for why are wages
and prices sticky
hadn't been well understood.
And I think we've really
made a lot of progress
in advancing that.
And, Greg, as you
mentioned, when
there is a financial crisis or
a period of high unemployment,
it does stimulate people to
think about macroeconomics
and to take off
in new directions.
And I think that's happened
since this financial crisis.
And, in particular,
I would point
to a growing body of work that's
at the board of finance theory
and macroeconomics that's
really helping us understand
the nature of systemic risk,
the way in which it can arise
and propagate
itself, what to look
for as we monitor the economy.
Obviously, we don't want to
have another financial crisis.
We want to do
everything in our power
to spot developments that could
produce a financial crisis.
And I think this work is going
to help us understand that.
But I would say that-- you
asked me about Tobin's work
and what's new and changed.
But I would say
Tobin's work continues
to have great relevance to
the problems we face today.
So as Ben well remembers,
it was December 2008.
We had lowered our overnight
short-term interest rate
to zero.
Unemployment was
still high and looked
like it could linger
for many, many years.
And we were searching
for new things
that we could do to
get the economy going.
And one of the things
that we ended up doing,
and other central
banks have as well,
was engaging in
large-scale purchases
of longer-term assets, in our
case, long-term treasury bonds
and mortgage-backed securities.
And the theory of
that was, in part,
that by removing these long-term
assets from the portfolio
with the public, we would
put downward pressure
on longer-term interest
rates, at a time when
there was no more to be
accomplished in the short end.
And really a lot of Tobin's
work on portfolio choice
and portfolio modeling, trying
to understand what determines
the relative rates of return
on different financial assets,
how demand and supply
mattered to that
was, in effect,
intellectual foundations
for those policies
and comparable ones
that are being used in
other parts of the world.
-It's maybe apocryphal,
but it's a legend,
an old Chinese
curse that says may
you live in interesting times.
And that certainly applies
to central bankers,
and you've lived in
very interesting times.
Looking back over
the past decade,
we've experienced a
tremendous financial crisis,
fear that that crisis would turn
into a Great Depression, which
it did not.
It turned into a
Great Recession.
The unemployment reached
10%, but not the 25%
that we saw in the 1930s.
So it sort of wasn't great
news, but it wasn't as bad
as it might have been.
So looking back at your time at
the Fed Federal Reserve system,
not just in your
current job, what
did the Fed do right,
and what did it do wrong?
-Well I think the Fed's handling
of the financial crisis,
once it was upon us, was
nothing short of magnificent.
And the credit here goes to Ben.
He was the right person with the
right intellectual background
and the courage to
think outside-the-box.
Two, he saw in the height
of the financial crisis,
credit just drying
up in the economy,
something that would end
up crippling businesses
and households and
could've ended us up
in another great recession.
And the immediate problem
that he and we in the Fed,
more generally, faced was how
to get credit flowing back
into the economy to avoid
that kind of outcome?
And although the Fed tends to
be a slow-moving and pretty
conservative institution, Ben
encouraged blue-sky thinking.
And he tasked
everybody around him
with being as inventive, as
innovative as they possibly
could to come up with
programs, some of them
might work some of them might
be rejected, might not work,
but to throw everything
we had at it,
to try to keep credit flowing
to the American economy.
We invented a whole
bunch of programs
with an alphabet of mnemonics.
I won't recall all
of them for you.
But I think that really stemmed
what was a very deep and severe
financial crisis.
And then after
that, the programs
that we adopted--
asset purchases
and forward guidance--
have made a difference
and gotten the economy
back on its feet.
So I think those are things that
the Fed can feel very proud of.
Ben was immensely
courageous in doing
this in the face of a
great deal of criticism,
and it was a huge contribution.
-I agree with you
completely, that Ben's
an absolute hero of this era.
But [INAUDIBLE] push you
just little bit on that.
Is there anything you
look back and say, I
wish we done that particular
thing differently?
I For example, I wish
we had saved Lehman?
Well, I will say
that we didn't see
the financial crisis coming.
Dean Cohen mentioned
my prescience,
which thank you for that,
in seeing the house price
bubble, which I did, and I
think others did as well.
But I don't think
we saw-- and this
is true for the
regulators, and, frankly,
it's true of
economists generally
and the private sector.
None of us saw--
well, we saw trees.
The house price overvaluation
or bubble was the tree.
There was growing leverage
in the shadow banking sector.
Some people saw that.
But putting it all
together, how this
would come together,
create systemic risk,
erupt into a very
severe financial crisis,
the rule of derivatives,
how they fit into that--
we really didn't
see that coming.
And, in that sense, I would
say we're really trying now
to do a better job of that.
It's a high priority.
-Well, that exactly brings
me to my next question,
because financial
regulation is obviously
an important part
of what the Fed does
and the federal government
more generally does, not
just the Fed.
Are we doing a better job
of financial regulation
today than we did before
the financial crisis?
-Absolutely.
I mean the short answer
is definitely, yes.
And the starting point for
why we're doing a better job
is that we're focused
on systemic risk.
We're focused on
financial stability
and wanting to spot
emerging conditions that
could potentially result in
another financial crisis.
And I think we have a
better understanding of how
to look for those
conditions, and we're
putting a lot of resources
and intellectual effort
into doing just that.
We now have an entire division
of financial stability
at the Fed.
With respect to our supervision
of the banking system,
really the most
important thing is
we're bringing a new mindset
to how we supervise the largest
and most systemic firms.
That, instead of taking
a tree sort of approach,
is this institution individually
look safe and sound?
We're thinking about
the interconnections
among these firms
and their connections
with other parts of
the financial system.
This is sometimes called a
macroprudential approach,
rather than a
microprudential approach.
Beyond that, in terms of
regulating the financial sector
and making the banking
system safer and sounder,
I think we've
accomplished a lot.
The amount of capital in the
banking system-- and this
is particularly true
for the largest and most
systemic firms-- has
increased enormously.
The quality of that capital
is greatly improved.
The amount of
liquidity that we're
requiring large banking
organizations to hold
is greatly increased.
And with greater
liquidity, there
are less chance that if
one firm encounters stress,
that will end up
mushrooming into a liquidity
shortage for the system as a
whole and a financial crisis.
We're also putting a great
deal of work into thinking how
to resolve the systemic firm,
if one were to fail or encounter
serious losses, without its
imposing costs on the taxpayer,
the so-called
too-big-to-fail problem.
We have forced firms to
produce living wills that
would show how they could
be safely dismantled,
using tools at our disposal.
And we're working very closely
with foreign regulators,
particularly in
England and in Europe,
to handle tricky
cross-border issues
and making sure that
we're all prepared.
So I do think things
have improved enormously.
-Let's turn to sort of
current economic conditions.
We've been in a recovery
stage for a while.
But it's been kind
of a slow recovery,
by historical standards.
How do you think
economy's doing right now?
-So it has been a slow recovery.
But we've made a great
deal of progress.
The unemployment rate peaked at
over 10%, and it's down to 5%
now.
Just over the last
year, we have created
around 2.7 million new
jobs, over 14 million
since the lowest
point for employment.
And more generally,
the labor market,
on almost any metric that
you could use to evaluate it,
is really improved.
Labor force participation
has moved up
some over the last year, which
is an encouraging development.
Because in a society that's
aging with more retirees,
there is a persistent
downward negative trend
in labor force participation.
So people who became
discouraged about finding work
have moved back into
the labor force.
So I definitely think we
have made a lot of progress.
But that said, I think the
further gains are possible.
So we're close to
an unemployment rate
that, I think, most
economists would associate
with our full employment goal.
But the number of individuals
working part time,
who would like to have full-time
jobs, is unusually high.
And we've really not
seen much improvement
in wage growth,
which is suggestive
of some slack in
the labor market.
Now, with the labor
markets improved,
a notable and less
positive development is
that the growth of output
has been remarkably slow,
something like 2% on average
over the last several years.
And when you have a lot
of jobs being created
in the face of not
much output growth,
unfortunately, that means
that productivity growth,
which is the growth in output
per worker, is very slow.
Over the last five years,
productivity growth
has averaged only half
a percent per year,
and that's a really
very miserable pace
in historical context.
Since productivity
growth ultimately
determines the
pace of improvement
in living standards
for society as a whole,
that's a serious and
negative development.
Finally I would say with
respect to inflation,
that inflation, for a
number of years now,
has been running below
the Fed's 2% objective.
This last year, our measure
of inflation that we look at
increased only
8/10 of a percent.
But very important reasons for
the shortfall are first of all,
the plunge we have
seen in oil prices,
and second of all, a
marked appreciation
of the dollar that's
pushed down import prices.
Those factors seem
like they're roughly
stabilizing at this point.
And my own expectation is that,
although inflation is lower
than our objective, if we
continue to see stability
there and an improving
labor market,
that inflation will move back
up over the next couple of years
to our 2% objective.
-I've been told that a bunch
of money managers in New York
have delayed their
trip to the Hamptons
this afternoon, so they
could listen to your talk
here today, in case
it moves markets.
So this is your chance
to move markets.
Do you want to tell us
anything about the path
of monetary policy
going forward?
You're welcome to say no.
And if you do say no, they'll
leave for the Hamptons.
-Well, let me say
a few sentences,
so I won't delay them very long.
So the economy is
continuing to improve.
We saw weak growth
in the first quarter
of the year and relatively weak
growth at the end of last year.
Growth looks to be picking
up from the various data
that we monitor.
And if that continues, and
if the labor market continues
to improve, and I expect
those things will occur,
we'll continue to
monitor incoming data,
and also we'll assess
risks to the outlook.
But it's appropriate--
and I've said this
in the past-- I
think for the Fed
to gradually and cautiously
increase our overnight interest
rate over time.
And probably in
the coming months
such a move would
be appropriate.
-Great.
You can go to the Hamptons now.
-That's it.
-One of the
interesting challenges
that the Feds faced recently
is the zero lower bound.
In fact, interest rates have
basically gone to rock bottom.
They've stayed there.
And some of the rules of
thumb, like a Taylor rule,
would suggest deeply
negative rates.
Now, we're not in a situation
now where it's a big concerned.
But people are worried.
I think Doug Elmendorf raised
this issue at this morning's
panel, that if we have
another recessionary shock
in the future, that the Feds
won't have many tools left.
How much does that worry you?
What do you imagine doing
in that sort of scenario?
Could you imagine going with
negative interest rates,
as some European countries
have been trying?
How do you think about that?
-So let me agree with what
Doug said this morning.
It is a concern.
We have very limited
scope at this point
to use our traditional
technique, namely lowering
overnight interest rates,
to support the economy
if there is an adverse shock.
Even if we go for some time
without an adverse shock,
and even if you take a
reasonably optimistic scenario,
participants in the FOMC
are asked to write down,
every three months,
what they regard
as a normal longer-run level
of short-term interest rates.
And so this is
something that they
might expect to prevail, say,
five to seven years from now,
so quite a ways down the road.
They write down the number
now, like 3% or 3 and 1/4%
is the median.
So even if we were to
go for a number of years
without encountering
and adverse shock,
and the short-term rates
got back to that level,
that's lower than a
lower level of rates
than we have seen historically.
We don't even know for sure that
the level of normal or neutral
rates will rise that high.
And in the typical-- I think
Doug mentioned this morning.
In a typical recession, when
the Fed wants to respond,
we would cut short-term interest
rates by maybe 400 or 500 basis
points.
So we don't have that scope.
Now, we did invent
other tools to address
stimulating the economy.
We use these longer-term
asset purchases.
And we try to shape
market expectations
about the path of
short-term interest rates
through our communications and
so-called forward guidance.
I think we would resort
to those tools again.
Negative interest
rates is something
we considered briefly.
We were concerned, at
the time, that there
could be a number of negative
repercussions from lowering
negative interest rates, from
lowering interest rates to zero
or a negative territory.
And so we didn't
really pursue that.
And it's not something
that we're really
thinking a great deal about now,
although other countries have
used it.
But this is a concern.
One of the reasons I believe
it's important for us
to be cautious in
raising interest rates
is precisely because if we were
to raise interest rates too
steeply and we were
to trigger a downturn
or contribute to a downturn,
we have limited scope
for responding.
And it is an important
reason for caution.
I would like to
see-- Doug and others
talked about this
morning-- that there
should be greater scope for
fiscal policy in the future,
to be usable to address
economic weakness.
And if we were to take
steps to raise productivity
growth-- and our
panelists talked
about a number of important
things-- education, children,
investment in infrastructure,
investment in innovation.
If we had faster
productivity growth,
that would probably push up the
normal level of interest rates
in the economy and give us a
bit more scope there as well.
-Great.
I have one final question.
I'm assuming out here in the
audience there's some students.
And I'm sure there's
some students who
are looking at you, and
they're saying, wow,
she's had a really cool career.
I want to do
something like that.
What advice would you
give that student?
-So I think the starting
point for me, as I've said
and others have
commented, was finding
a subject I loved and
have been able to feel
passionate about over all
these years of my career,
namely economics.
And obviously, it's not going
to be economics for everybody.
But finding some
field, some interest
that you want to get up every
day, you want to work on.
Obviously, a successful career
it does require hard work,
and it's a lot less hard
if what you're working on
is something you're
really interested in.
So to me, that's key.
I guess I would also say
that something that's
been important to
me-- in thinking
about a career-- I know I've
achieved a remarkable position.
But it's not just the endpoint
of one's career that matters.
A satisfying career
is about what
you do all the way throughout
your working years,
leading up to wherever it ends.
And for me, when I think
back on all the stages,
I've enjoyed them all.
They've all been
satisfying, partly
because I love economics.
But also I'll mention
two or three things.
One thing, I think it's really
important to affiliate yourself
with organizations that
you really feel identified
with their mission, that
you feel proud that you
work for the organization.
I've certainly felt that way
at the various universities.
I've been at.
And I felt that way
very much working
in the federal government.
Several of our
panelists this morning
talked about public service.
And I will say that some
of the finest, smartest,
most dedicated, most passionate
people that I've worked with
have been at the Federal Reserve
and in the federal government.
But throughout, finding
people to work with that
you brainstorm together.
You have to figure
out what are we
going to do about this problem?
And coming into work and
having a group of people you
feel these are people I
want to hang out with.
I feel proud to have these
people as my colleagues.
That's always been
important to me--
so the people you work with
and choosing organizations.
Somebody says,
where do you work?
I work at the Federal Reserve.
I feel proud of that.
I feel it's an
important organization.
It's devoted to the
well-being of America.
-Well, thank you very much.
Thank you.
-Thank you very much,
Greg, for leading us
in such a stimulating
conversation.
I think we've all had
a great tutorial today.
And it will stick with us,
I think, for a long time.
And to Chair Yellen,
thank you for sharing
your time, your experiences,
and your wisdom with us today.
Now the moment has come to
confer upon you the 2016
Radcliffe Medal.
She unites scholarship and
leadership for the public good.
She brings candor
and collegiality
to solving complex problems.
She strives to build an economy
in which all Americans can
thrive.
Chair Janet Yellen, I bestow
upon you this Radcliffe Medal,
with the deepest
admiration for a lifetime
of visionary and
principled service.
-Thank you.